[Music]
hey you guys
time for another tomes of terror and on
this
installment we are going to be talking
about this little mind [ __ ] of a book
right here
i'm thinking of ending things by ian
reed
now the reason i decided to review this
particular book
this particular week i had actually
scheduled to do another one this week
but i pushed this one up in the rotation
because only a couple of days ago
i noticed that netflix had dropped a
movie adaptation of this novel uh
directed by charlie kaufman of all
things
so i thought it would be very
interesting um to
read the book and watch the movie and
then compare the two
this isn't going to be a movie review
necessarily because i mostly want to
focus on the book
but i will kind of get into how the book
differs from the movie in some ways
without really spoiling anything
so like i said just as i said in all my
previous reviews
i'm not going to spoil anything i'm not
going to spoil the big reveal
at the end of this book but you know
some things that i say
might be considered like mild spoilery
or might give you more information about
the book than you might want
going into it so if you're the kind of
person that likes to go into things like
knowing as little about them as possible
you might not want to watch this until
after you've read the book now the book
is very
short it's only like 250 uh pages and
some of it and actually it's uh
pretty the leading is pretty large if
you're a graphic designer you know what
i'm talking about that means there's a
lot of space between the lines
so it's so it's really not very long at
all
i read it probably in about three hours
over a day or two so
you know it's doesn't take that long so
it sounds like something that you would
like
after you know i've kind of sold it a
little bit then um
read it and then come back and we'll
talk about it so like i said i've
actually had this book
in my to read and to review pile
for probably a month or two because
it was one of those books that um kept
getting recommended by a bunch of
different other uh you know book review
channels that i watch and like
on goodreads and things like that it has
pretty high ratings on there so i was
eventually gonna get to this one but
when i saw that the movie came out i was
like oh why not you know it'll it'll be
timely it'll be topical
so this is the first novel of writer ian
reed he's canadian
i believe uh he had written two books
prior to this but they were both
non-fiction
so as i said this is first fictional
novel
now it seems to have gotten um pretty
high critical praise
uh it's gotten on like it was on npr's
like best books of the year list all
this other stuff it came out in 2016 i
believe
but it does really seem like the critics
seem to love it a lot of the readers
like on goodreads and on the other book
review sites seem to love it however
there is a contingent of people
that really really did not like it or
really really didn't seem to get it
so let's talk about that a little bit
because i will say
i mean i really liked this book i found
it very um
unsettling and it gave me like some
really weird
dreams but uh the thing about this book
is that i would call it
literary horror not in the way that it's
written um because it's actually very
terse and very straightforward so the
text is not like
flowery or not hard to understand or
anything like that in any
way shape or form but just in the
themes that it explores and the fact
that it's tinged with
surrealism it doesn't really give you
a definitive narrative in the sense that
you know things happen in it and it has
like a story to it like you know
people go to a place and this happens
and this happens
but a lot of the stuff that happens in
the book
is internalized like internalized
monologue
internalized and there's like a lot of
philosophical
discussions like between the characters
there's a lot of references
to other books other poems which aren't
always pointed out
so it's almost kind of like a puzzle
story and this is
definitely definitely a book that needs
two reads i mean once you get to the end
and you find out what has been going on
like what the big reveal is
it's probably instructive to go back and
read it again
so you can just kind of pick up all the
threads and see where the little
breadcrumbs were that was leading to
that final
revelation at the end and i actually do
want to read this again
this strikes me very much i would still
call it a horror novel it's not a
thriller
it's not it's not a ghost story it's not
anything like that this is more i
i guess it's more psychological horror
but like i said it's also very literary
in the sense that it has like a much
deeper meaning
it's not real action-packed it's not
nothing like that
but the thing about this book is that
i can't really put my finger on it it's
very funny because one of the um
one of the things on the back of the
book uh says the description of the book
says
you will be scared but you won't know
why and i'm like
yeah that's a pretty like succinct
summation of what's going on in this
book because
before you really know what's going on
it's almost kind of like
you know as things are happening in the
book and then like the character is
thinking things or saying things and it
almost seems
random but even though it's
random it's still like just these
little random things kind of like worm
their way into your head and it's just
like
it's really like constructs this
enormous
structure of menace and like unease
and you're not even entirely sure like
where that's coming from
like some of the images that you know
that they talk about
in the story um or you know that's that
one of the
characters is thinking about are really
are horrific
images but i think it's not even just
that i mean that helps obviously
but just the little details in this
are just so creepy and then like in
total even if you are not entirely sure
what they mean
especially like during your first
read-through even if you're not even
entirely sure what they mean
it still just kind of like just drips
away and it just kind of
constructs this entire like edifice of
like eeriness that
it's really really hard to shake off and
this is one of those books that like
after i read it i was like thinking
about it for like
a couple of days afterward because i was
like man that was
messed up you know what i mean so
basically if you want
a plot synopsis because this is not a
real
plot heavy book the plot is not
important
so the plot of this book is that
there is the narrator who is the unnamed
girlfriend of a guy named jake
now she has been thinking
about quote unquote ending things that's
actually the first sentence of the novel
i'm thinking about ending things which
is also the title obviously
um and you're led to believe that and
the way that she thinks like her
internal monologue um you're led to
believe that
uh her and jake she really likes him as
a dude and like
you know they've been having a good time
they've been dating for six or seven
weeks she's not entirely clear
but she just thinks it's not gonna work
out maybe it would be better off if
maybe she would be better off if she was
alone and that kind of goes off on a
whole philosophical tangent of
on relationships on if you can ever know
somebody else on
you know are humans better off being
alone because you know you don't have
all this
drama all these other things going on so
she's been thinking about that but she
hasn't told jake
this yet um so they are going to
meet his parents now this is not
set in any particular place i was
assuming it was like some rural place in
canada because that's where ian reed is
from
but it could really be anywhere like any
kind of rural place like out in the
middle of a snowstorm
so they're basically driving a long way
out to
the farm where jake grew up and she's
gonna meet his parents
so she's kind of going back and forth
with herself like she kind of feels
guilty
that i'm going to meet his parents and
like she thinks that's gonna
that he's gonna have expectations
because of that and
you know she feels bad because she's
thinking about breaking up with him and
it's like maybe we shouldn't have come
on this trip
but then on the other hand she's also
very conflicted about maybe
maybe everything's gonna be okay and
maybe she doesn't really think she can't
really think of any reason why
like why she wants to break up with him
necessarily like he's not a bad dude
it's like you know he's he's nice and
she like
talks about all the things she likes
about him both physically and you know
about um
you know his personality and like his
intelligence and
things of that nature so that's kind of
going on so the probably the first
third of the book is just them in the
car
and her thinking about
you know the impending breakup and kind
of
waxing philosophical about that and also
kind of
you know when she sees certain things
like she'll have memories about stuff
that
happened to her in childhood or
something like that like like in one
particular
uh very unsettling scene which i don't
know why it kind of stuck with me but
where she was talking about one of the
scariest things she ever saw and
when she was a child you know she woke
up once and saw a man
outside of her window but the creepiest
detail about it i don't know why this
creeps me out so much
but um the creepiest detail about it was
that she thought he was looking
at her even though he was so tall that
his head was like
you know over the level of the top of
the window so there's no way that he
could have been
he could have seen in unless he was like
ducking down so she was so she just sees
like his torso and like part of his legs
and it's like he's just standing there
and then like he waves at her
and for some reason that like i was just
like nope the [ __ ] out on that i'm like
i don't know why that unsettles me so
much but it's just it's little [ __ ] like
that
and you don't even really know until the
end
and even maybe not even then like what
those images mean like what they all add
up to
but it just like all adds to this like
really really
eerie like this kind of mounting tension
and this is everything's kind of like
menacing but not exactly and you're not
even really sure why it's menacing
so the first third of the book like i
said is them having like philosophical
conversations like he's
um a physicist and um or something of
that nature so they kind of have some
discussions about that
and um you know and like i said this
whole time she's kind of like
having memories and thinking about her
future with him thinking about how they
met
um you know and and thinking about
ending it if it's fair and all these
other things
so then like the second act of the book
is when they actually get to jake's
parents
farmhouse and then it gets even like
more unsettling because they get there
it's like like i said it's a snowstorm
they're just going there for dinner and
like for her to meet them and
they're not planning to stay overnight
or anything like that it's just a visit
so it's this farmhouse but it's like
really remote and there's not really
that many animals on it and then she
sees a couple things on there that are
kind of
disturbing but not in a way that you
know not in a way you'd be like oh
they're serial killers it's stuff that
you would normally see around a farm but
it's still like creepy if you're not
used to growing up in that environment
and then when she actually meets his
parents there's all kind of little
things that happen in the house that are
just like really really
off like about the two of them not and
like i said it's not in a menacing way
they don't seem evil they don't come
across
like they're gonna kill her they don't
come across anything like that
but there's just all these little bitty
things like they take too long to come
downstairs almost like they didn't know
that they were coming
um you know what like the mom acts
really strange like one of her toenails
is missing it's just like all this
really creepy [ __ ]
like that kind of stuff at some point uh
the girlfriend like i said who doesn't
have a name in the story because she's
the narrator
you know goes down to the basement she
finds these really weird drawing and she
goes up to jake's
old room supposedly and like looks
around and finds all these things and
talks to his dad for a bit so there's
that whole thing
so then when they leave uh the parents
house like the storm is getting been
getting worse and worse
and the you know the parents say oh you
know you can stay and everything but
she's like no we have to get back we
have to work tomorrow
and then for some reason they decide to
stop
at dairy queen because jake wants
something sweet
so they stop at dairy queen and then you
know they decide they don't
want like what they got there like after
they leave because it's like freezing
cold outside
and so he insists oh we have to go down
this like really remote
road to this high school because we have
to throw these cups away
or you know the you know it'll melt in
the cup holders and it'll get the cup
holders all sticky and i don't really
have to deal with that like i don't like
the cups being in the car so
they go down this really long lonely
road to like this big huge
high school that's like out of the
middle of nowhere and uh so he can go
get rid of the cops
so the whole third act takes place at
this school
where basically i don't really want to
spoil this
part because this was like really creepy
so
so it's like in three parts kind of so
it's like going to the parents house
at the parents house and then after they
leave the parents house and all the
creepy [ __ ] that happens after that
with him going into the school for a
reason i won't disclose
you know so it and then like the the
last third of it almost becomes like
almost like a stalker or like a chase
type of thing like through this darkened
high school or whatever
that's what the plot is but as i said
there's a lot going on
underneath all the stuff like in the
thoughts that she's having
and it's really really hard to talk
about without saying what the reveal is
as i said if you if you like literary
horror if you like surreal horror if you
just like something
that that you don't necessarily have to
understand it but it's just like a bunch
of
creepy unsettling images that kind of
worm their way into your brain if you
are into that type of stuff then you
will probably love this book
now let's talk a little bit about the
movie adaptation so i just watched the
movie adaptation
yesterday uh as i said it was directed
by charlie kaufman
who if you don't know who that is he
also did adaptation he did eternal
sunshine and spotless mind being john
malkovich
all great movies so
he was probably the best person to adapt
this book because the way when i heard
that there was a movie made of it
i was just like how are you even gonna
do that man it's like
it's one of those things where i just
had no if somebody asked me to adapt it
i'd be
hosed because i'd be like i would have
no idea like how to approach it
so i can see why they gave it to
somebody like charlie kaufman who
is you know quite known for doing this
type of thing like this
surrealist oh he also made cynic dosh
new york which is also a great movie if
you haven't seen that
one thing i will say about the movie
adaptation i did like it
but it's a lot different than the book
like kind of the plot beats
are the same the reveal is the same
generalities are the same but i feel
like the little
bits of it are different in a way that
almost puts it in a different genre
like the movie i don't think i would
call that a horror movie
at all the movie is more like a weird
philosophical
like kind of depressing but also kind of
weirdly funny
movie like it has creepy moments but
nothing like the book i mean
when i saw it and like i said it's not a
ding against the movie i'm just saying
that it's different enough that i don't
even think it's the same genre as the
book i don't think
i would even call it a horror movie by
any stretch of the imagination it's
really really not
charlie kaufman added a lot of stuff
that wasn't in the book like all the
stuff about if you've seen the movie
like all the stuff in there about
oklahoma
um all of this stuff about um
uh you know the references he made to
like a beautiful mind the references he
made to some other movies and other
uh you know books and poems and stuff
that was not
in the book but i don't mind that he had
it because like i said it's it's his own
vision and he's kind of known for
i mean very famously uh his movie
adaptation was actually about the
process of adapting
the orchid thief which again was another
book that was very because i read it
many years ago which was another book
that you know a lot of people said it
was really really hard to adapt and he
had such a hard time adapting it that he
made a movie
about adapting it that also incorporated
the book that he was trying to adapt you
know what i mean so he's very into like
doing those kind of meta textual kind of
things
which like i said that's probably what
made him like the perfect choice
to do a movie like this but on the other
hand
i do feel like it it strayed so far from
the source material or the spirit of the
source material
that i don't think that it's a horror
movie anymore i didn't find the movie
creepy it was weird and it was i'm not
even really sure what to say you know it
was just like a weird surreal movie but
it didn't like
creep me out the way the book creeped me
out and a lot of the things in the
movie were kind of done like you know
the the part at the end like in the
schoolhouse
was kind of done like it was well lit
and everything and that's not really how
i was picturing it
because the end he changed the end quite
a lot like the third act
um you know when i was picturing it when
i was reading the book i just pictured
everything being
dark because i mean that's kind of how
they describe how he described it
in the novel like her just kind of
creeping around through this
darkened school and there was just like
little exit lights and
and it was like really scary you know
and and then uh
so the whole book i mean i've i kind of
felt like
this really isolating insular kind of
you know everything's dark it's like
everything's covered with snow
there's like all the split so it was
just very claustrophobic
and i didn't really get that so much
from the movie
so keep that in mind but the weird thing
about it though is like i'm watching the
movie and i'm thinking to myself
so even though a lot of stuff was
changed from the book
i was like if you had not read the book
prior to watching the movie
i don't think you would have any idea
what was going on in that movie
maybe you would it's like it's hard for
me to say because i because i finished
reading the book and then like the next
day i watched the movie
so maybe like more astute people than me
would like watch the movie and they
would figure it out
but i doubt it i mean i kind of doubt it
i don't know
like the book to me seemed it's not
straightforward but i didn't really find
it all that difficult like when the end
came when the reveal came at the end
i was like oh i get it like you know and
i'm not gonna say
but i figured out what was going on
um and the fact that i figured out what
was going on that's why i want to go
back and read it again because i want to
see like all the little tendrils that
had kind of come together at the end
but apparently like i've read some other
reviews of the book
where people were just like what the
[ __ ] did i just read i don't get it
like what happened at the end you know i
don't understand
but to me it seemed pretty obvious what
was going on
uh the movie did not seem obvious to me
even though i knew
what the uh what the reveal was even
though i knew what was going on
i was thinking to myself if i hadn't
read the book i just would not have any
idea
like what was going on in this movie so
in that way like the movie is actually
pretty challenging
you know it's it's just real weird and i
feel like if you don't
if you haven't read the book like you'll
just be clueless as to like what all
these images mean
and everything but i don't know your
mileage may vary i'd be interested to
know
uh if anybody watching this has seen the
movie but not read the book and if you
figured out what was going on or you
know what or or what you thought like if
you
read the book and saw the movie i'd be
interested to know
like what you thought of the adaptation
i liked the movie
but it just didn't seem anything like
the book to me
other than in the most general sense
it didn't have the same spirit as the
book had it didn't have the same
mood to me i mean that might just be me
i'm not really sure
you know like i said everyone's got a
different opinion so i'd be interested
to hear yours about it
but yeah so as i said i would recommend
this
to anybody that really likes
surreal type of stuff kind of more quote
unquote elevated type of horror if you
like a24 movies if you like anything
like that
you would probably dig it it's not you
know it's one of those ones where it's
like a puzzle
kind of so keep that in mind that it's
not going to be
this real straightforward a lot of it is
just like internal monologue
flashback memories weird imagery
um it's not that inscrutable but
if you're used to just real
straightforward
horror you know this happened that
happened that happened like and we
killed the vampire or whatever
i don't think you're gonna like it
because i think you might find it a
little too
obtuse um so if you don't like that kind
of thing
you you probably will not like this but
that said i mean i like all kinds of
horror
so i really actually kind of dug this
book i wasn't sure i was going to when i
first started reading it
because when i first started reading it
like this very terse writing style and
i'm sitting there thinking is this going
to be
too pretentious is it going to bother me
but i only thought that for like a page
or two
and then i just got sucked right into it
and as i said the more it went on and
like these just little details and like
little creepy imagery and stuff started
to build up and build up
until it just kind of you know
constructed this whole entire
world out of darkness and snow and
weirdness and it's just
it almost kind of like encases you in a
bubble in that way
and um and i found that after i finished
reading it it really kind of
stuck with me you know what i mean like
it's just images from it kept like
coming up in my mind it gave
you know i even had dreams that were
kind of like that you know what i mean
they were like kind of referencing or
you know
glancing blow like some of the book or
whatever but yeah it's
you know i found it very very unsettling
and that's what i like in horror so if
you like that too
then uh give it a read uh if you like
surrealism if you like unsettling type
of horror which i do everybody knows i
dig that kind of thing
then check it out i'm thinking of ending
things and the reason it's crossed out
and then
not crossed out is because that title
has a
double meaning which you probably could
have figured out for
yourself i just thought i'd tell you
anyway but yeah so
that'll do it for this tomes of terror
i'll be back next week with another one
so bye